what is going on guys welcome back to
the channel and for today's video we're
going to be talking about the season 1
rewards for overwatch now as all of you
probably know if you click on this video
overwatch competitive is going to be
ending in the next week or so around 5
p.m. pacific standard time roughly like
that's what the but i think that's what
blizzard put and on blizzard's website
they did explain a couple days ago the
rewards that you will be getting before
i get into that i would just like to
thank mr. taco for sending me that intro
that you all saw on the video I'll leave
this channel in the description if you
guys want to check that [ __ ] out a big
thanks to him so let's get on with the
video so basically every player that is
competed or yeah competing and
competitive will get a player icon and a
spray saying hey I play competitive
that's it the next one you're going to
be getting is competitive points the
competitive points are you get a a
decent amount depending on your skill
rank if you are skill rank 0 to 39 then
you get 10 if you are skilled rank 40 to
45 it will be 2046 249 you'll get forty
or forty if you have a skill rating of
52 52 you'll beginning 60-53 256 is 80
where I'm at which is 56 259 is 120 any
player that's at 62 64 is 200 and then
the top players which is 65 and higher
will give 300 competitive points or
basically one free golden weapon because
everybody knows that it takes 300
competitive points to get a golden
weapon the only problem that I'd see
with these golden weapons is that
even the shittiest player at skill rank
leg zero 39 yes they're getting 10
competitive points but if they do have
enough time in their day all they gotta
do is just play and then if you win a
game you get a competitive point and if
you just play a [ __ ] ton of games you'll
have enough to get these golden weapons
but I do think it is nice that overwatch
is giving the players that are really
high ranked the web basically a free
weapons the product the last thing that
you will be getting for the season 1
award about my favorite thing they added
a new system so that if you're playing
with one of the top 500 players in
competitive it shows it underneath their
scale rating whether they're number one
in the world or 500 in the world and it
will even show it for you if you happen
to be one of those top 500 clearly I'm
not but if you are one of the top 500
once you log in to overwatch after the
season ends you will give a limited
edition animated spray which is the only
animated spray believe in all of
overwatch which i think is pretty nice I
guess uh in terms of the rewards it's
not bad really I think I have like 30 or
40 competitive points and then if I
don't play competitive at all i'll be at
120 so i have about 160 which will leave
me about halfway through to getting a
gold weapon but i'm not big on the gold
weapons it basically only people that
are going to see it or you and then the
person you kill if they look at your
killcam so it's more of a kind of a
bragging rights to your friend I guess
if you want to call it that up other
than that that's the only thing that's
going to be giving at the end of the
season 1 overwatch competitive which
once again ends august seventeenth or
august 18 at like 5pm somewhere around
there
other than that guys I hope you did
enjoy the video if you did enjoy the
video though like this video comment
your opinion also comment below what you
think they should have added more to
what else that they should they give us
competitive players that actually have
played it should they have given like
more bonuses to the people that are
higher or other than just CP like maybe
a certain spray that you get depending
on if you're like if you're like skill
writing 50 and higher you're in like the
upper tier you get your own certain
spray or something else like that or
maybe even a skin they could have added
for I've character you're choosing or
something like that but just come in
your opinion what you think about that
and once again guys subscribe all you
got to do scroll down in the video click
the subscribe button it takes two
seconds other than that guys I hope you
guys did enjoy and have a good rest of
your day peace
you